[Music]
by the light of the moon
a group of youth sneaked into the woods
where they take mind-altering substances
switch it up romantically and brush up
against creatures from another dimension
a midsummer night's dream sees
Shakespeare gets psychedelic and the
result is a treat in the theatre and on
the page first performed in the 1590s
this play is one of Shakespeare's frisky
aswer --xx filled with trickery madness
and magic set over the course of one
night Midsummer progresses at a
rollicking pace the plot is structured
around patterns of collision and
dissolution where characters from
different worlds are thrown together and
torn apart Shakespeare uses these
patterns to mock the characters
self-obsession and question authority
with a comic twist the action is set in
ancient Greece but like many of
Shakespeare's plays it reflects his
contemporary concerns the magical
setting of the woods at night disrupts
the boundaries between separate groups
with bizarre results here The Bard plays
with the rigid class system of his own
time taking three distinct groups and
turning their society upside down in a
world where no mortal is in control the
play opens with young Hermia raging at
her father Aggies and Theseus the king
of Athens who have forbidden her to
marry her lover
Lysander Hermia has no interest in her
father's choice for her of Demetrius but
her best friend Helena definitely does
furious at their elders Hermia and
Lysander elope under cover of darkness
with Demetrius in hot pursuit this is
further complicated by Helena decision
to follow them all into the woods in the
hope of winning Demetrius is Hart at
this point the woods are getting crowded
as the lovers are sharing the space with
a group of rude mechanicals a troupe of
workers drunkenly rehearsing a play led
by the jovial Nick bottom unbeknownst to
them the humans have entered into the
world of the fairies
despite their magical splendor Oberon
and titania the king and queen of the
fairies have their own romantic problems
furious at his inability to control
titania the jealous Oberon commands the
trickster puck to squeeze the juice of a
magical flower over her eyes when she
wakes up she'll fall in love with the
first thing she sees on his mission puck
gleefully sprinkles the juice over the
eyes of the napping Demetrius and
Lysander and transforms bottoms head
into that of a donkey for good measure
as eyes flicker open a night of chaos
commences that includes broken hearts
mistaken identity and transformations
out of all the characters bottom
probably fares the best when the
bewitched titania lays eyes on him she
calls on her fairies to lavish him with
wine and treasures and sweeps the
transfigured donkey man off his feet
pluck the wings from painted butterflies
to fan the moonbeams from his sleeping
eyes not to him elves and do him
courtesies while magic is the catalyst
to the action the play reflects the real
drama of the things we do for love and
the nonsensical behavior of the people
under its spell the moon overlooks the
action like a silver bow signifying
erratic behavior the dark side of love
and the bewitching allure of a world
where the usual rules don't apply
although the characters eventually come
to their senses a Midsummer Night's
Dream raises the question of how much
agency we have over our own daily lives
but it's not them more realistically
rendered lovers rulers or workers who
have the last word but the impish puck
who queries whether we can ever truly
trust what we see if we shadows have
offended think but this and all is
mended that you have but slumber'd here
while these visions did appear
and in so doing he evokes the effect of
entering into the magical world of great
theatre that plays with the boundary
between illusion and reality and
dramatizes the possibility that life is
but a dream
want more Shakespeare check out our why
you should read Macbeth episode and get
a crash course in one of Shakespeare's
most tragic tales
[Music]